yes I asked myself that and you know
what's I I did right straight
philosophical pieces but in the last
book I had had written which was on
Spinoza Victorian Spinoza the renegade
you gave us my dear to be I had you know
that was a straight more or less
intellectual biography with a lot of
philosophy in it that book introduced me
to communities I hadn't known about
before organized non-religion was
shocking that no religion can be as
organized as religion well not quite as
organized but lots and lots of you know
associations of pro-science pro reasons
some more or less anti-religious and I
had the sense that the more and I got
invited to these to these groups to talk
the more I spoke to people with whom I
basically agreed the more dissatisfied I
became when they discussed people with
whom I don't agree I know very well what
it's like to be religious I know very
well what it's like to experience the
world that way and I know that it has to
do with more than argumentation and it
has in fact more to do then with the
belief in God it's got to do with
community and loyalty and existential
dilemmas and fear of death and just so
many different emotions and that
religious people often just experience
the world very differently than then
than others and for me fiction which I
which I love is is made for that kind of
thing to show how these big issues are
really embedded in lives how they often
are connected with completely different
experiences of the world that they go
very deep down so deep down that often
people who don't agree are just they're
just not hearing these are other they're
not grasping each other they don't know
what it feels like to inhabit the world
that other person's way fiction is made
for that and that's what drove me once
again against my self-interest to write
another another novel
yes I mean it's interesting as a
philosopher it surprised me how suddenly
you know it all seemed very quiet when I
used to teach you know philosophy of
religion or arguments for the existence
of God you know deconstructing them you
know 20 25 years ago it was you know
really you know was not didn't provoke a
lot of discussion in the classroom but
now it's really escaped from the
classroom it's in the public square and
it's interesting why now clearly 911 had
a lot to do with it the more dangerous
aspects of you know absolute belief
undoubted belief is very very we're all
in terror of this right now so this
certainly had something to do with it I
think also the Alliance the political
alliance that took place in the last
administration between you know free
market advocates and Family Values
evangelical Christians as a political as
a large and powerful political movement
had something also to do with the
pushback from from the other side
important decisions that affect us all
like stem cell research or gay marriage
being decided by people from a
particular religious background with a
particular religious agenda it was
distressing due to two other people and
so there was a pushback I also think
there's something about the progress in
the brain sciences in evolutionary
psychology in particular so that
religious belief is now something that
scientists are looking at and trying to
explain and it's not a I don't think a
an accident that the most prominent
atheists writers come from that domain
Richard Dawkins from evolutionary by all
sam Harris Dan Dennett also much
interested in evolution evolutionary
psychology so I think that that also a
way to try to now explain religious
belief as a way of toning it down